hi it's me i'm drew and i'm sitting down
with one of the most successful
supermodels of all time she got the
nickname nikkie6 for simultaneously
being on six magazine covers in just one
month i absolutely love this woman i'm
really excited to talk to her about
her career and being a mom and decisions
she has to make i really relate and i'm
excited to hear her life advice ladies
and gentlemen without further ado nikki
taylor
hi drew it's so nice to finally meet you
oh my god nikki thank you so much for
doing this with us truly
yes no
thank you how do you think that the
industry has changed over you know the
last few years i mean it's changed a lot
right i mean when you and i first
started we were shooting with film
and you know one more roll one more roll
i just remember this and now
everything's i know the good good old
days right polaroid
wait for the polaroid right
and now everything's digital and super
fast social media which you are very
good at and i need to take some pointers
from you
um
i like to pop in and pop back out
if your daughter came to you and said
that she wanted to like model because i
have those conversations with olive and
frankie all the time you know like if
you had to do something today as a job
what would you do today how does your
daughter look at life what does she want
to be today what do you think she says
she wants to be when she grows up
so drew just short three years ago she
wanted to be a mermaid
and today we are in seventh grade and
we're just trying to figure out middle
school and get through the day
our entertainment world if that's
something that she wanted to do
and she was passionate about absolutely
i would support her in anything she's
passionate about the modeling world is
industry has been so good to me and
women have been supporting my career
um this whole time so this is why i i
love giving back i love missions like
dress for success and talbots also being
a partner with them
and it's it's the women helping women so
yes so absolutely anything my daughter
wants to do as well as my sons you know
i support them okay well we're teaming
up with talbots today and you're working
with them and dress for success on a new
initiative
yes so talbot's is celebrating their
75th anniversary
and dress for success is celebrating
their 25th
so in honor of
all the amazing women that dress for
success has impacted talbot's design
these three comfy sweatshirts
so 30 of the net proceeds will be going
to dress for success
and they're available at talbots.com as
well as the retail stores will you tell
me about the talbot's inspiring
challenge
yes so everybody has someone who has
inspired them and we want to hear from
you we want you to share your story on
social media with the hashtag who
inspires you and also tag talbot's
official do you think that nikki you and
i could kick it off and
we could
take a picture of ourselves in these
sweatshirts i will get one from talbots
i wish i was wearing it right now oh
my god the magic
yeah right so you have the inspire one
so i'm going to put this on and take a
picture of myself and maybe you could
take a picture of yourself in the
strength one i love the detail of the
shoulder by the way
and we could put a picture of ourselves
side by side and kick it off and say
everybody tag talbots and do the hashtag
who inspires you
and we could kind of lead the charge on
it i would give anything to be next to
you in a photograph so i would love to
you know that so let's do a side by side
and then we'll send it out on social
media on both of our channels and on
talbots and we'll invite other women to
join us
yes i would love that thank you thank
you so much drew
[Music]
you